recite the alphabet from start to finish
without singing it yeah okay look you
can already tell this is going to be a
[__] travesty in a train wreck
because of the way the cop is
being she's got this woman is pulled
over for a you know drunk driving I bet
I guess right using my deductive
reasoning here I'm not sure luck
but the [__] Shure attitude he has in
the voice you know he's already got her
in he's got it in the bag right you know
he's like he's got it in the [__] bag
he's like well this this lady's going to
be right she's gonna we got we got her
it was like that [__] been ladies and
gentlemen we got
them whenever you're ready whenever
you're ready is so low whenever you're
ready sweetie pie come on he might as
well have said sweetie pie whenever
you're ready sweetie pie you recite the
alphabet from start to finish without
singing it yeah okay when without
singing it what's that all about you
ready [__] that no I don't do that I'll
sing it hey B C D E F G like this h i j
k L man o p q r
s
t v dou x y and
[Music]
z god dude my son would laugh so hard at
what I just
did here we go here we go here we go
here we go come on recite the alphabet
from start to finish without singing it
yeah okay whenever you're ready
AC
dudee that's like a character drunk
ACB
a
c
b d e f g h h i f n
g h i FNG G she's just spelling words
incorrectly h i c k l m n o p h q e s oh
dude saying
websites dude she threw another h on the
back end and she threw another h on the
back
end h q e s i t e
oh it's Coy she spelled dude the cop
just shoots her okay all right the way
he said okay all right well so you're
going to jail for 25 years could you
recite the alphabet from start to finish
without singing it bro yeah okay
whenever you're ready ACB so let's what
these are ACB b e f g h a a
ACB D EFG
s s was one was three letter uh a c h h
i f n g f i n g f i n g thing um hi i c
k hi i c k hick L M N O P LM o p there
you go if she got that wrong that would
be that's that's the crazy run of the
alphabet if you get LMN o p wrong you
are brain dead you're vegetable you're
basically a chair that's unbelievable if
you get lmop she got that right that's
not saying much she could be like her
blood alcohol level could be five she
still get elemental P right then it's
QRS let's see what she says HQ s
HQ s dude a video game system
Dark Knight available on everything
except for
HQ HQ s HQ s so she's she's confirming
by the way it is HQ s it it okay all
right okay all right go to jail for 90
years uh do the the fact that she thinks
that the alphabet ends with
e is unreal
dude wow for real throw her under the
jail bro how many H well so first thing
is first
first how tell I really forget how many
hes are actually in the alphabet first
so you can tell me
please H AB b c hi i j k h j k l m h j
KP q h j
k
h